so um I was 13 or 14 I believe I was in
summer of like 8th grade to ninth grade
and
um I had a best friend and she at the
time we were going into high school and
she
she liked this guy and I actually liked
that guy's best friend so she liked his
name was Edwin I liked his Edwin's best
friend
um
and Edwin is actually who you know I'm
going to be talking about it's just
that's how we met so
they ended up not working out my best
friend and him but I just knew him from
her and there was something about him
that I I don't know what it was it
wasn't even that I was like attracted to
him but I I just had this like I don't
know like he just had my attention all
the time and I remember they stopped
kind of being a thing but we all kept in
touch and through just high school and
this and that
um yeah I don't know I just always kept
in touch with him I would always talk to
him on you know social media and I
remember it was ninth grade I remember
the exact it was February 14th uh 20.
2010
I was going to the movies and I said you
know what let me invite Edwin and I
invited him and he brought a friend and
I brought my friend and that's kind of
like I can remember to this day what he
was wearing what I was wearing we saw
Avatar and I just remember that was the
start of
of us
we had a really great time and then I
remember the next day we our next day
not the next day the next weekend we
went to I think it was like another
movie or whatnot we're talking you know
non-stop I was in again ninth ninth or
tenth grade at the time and it was just
you know young like fun I never really
had a boyfriend so it was just like
young fun romance
um I guess you could say and then the
following weekend I remember we went
bowling
had a great time we were having fun and
I went to bowl and I went and turned
around and he was standing right there
and he was like I want to know if you
want to be my girlfriend
and so obviously I said yes
um my first boyfriend was really
exciting and yeah that was just kind of
the start of it um
I don't even know where
he was six months older than me but he
was in a great above me so I was in uh I
Believe by this point I was a sophomore
and he was a junior that's that makes
sense and um yeah it was just so easy
like him and I got along so well
um I'm half El Salvadorian and he was El
Salvadorian so we had that in common uh
I have a sister who's 15 years younger
than me my mom had her really late
um and he had a brother that was 15
years younger than him so we just had a
lot in common
we went to different high schools but we
had friends that were
um
that were that you know we had similar
friends so
um yeah it was just it was really it was
a good relationship and I was really
young at the time but I just remember
just being so happy and so I mean I
loved him and there was nothing really
wrong like we rarely ever fought uh we
just even my mom like my mom started to
grow on him and all my friends started
to love him and love us together and
um so it was great but then I remember
it was about like a year and a half
um I was it was a summer of my senior
year and he had graduated already
going into a community college and I
just remember just feeling super serious
and I knew deep in the back of my head
that he was the one I don't think I
really thought that like it wasn't it
was like a subconscious thing I just in
my gut I knew that like him and I were
just so good and that scared me being
you know so young and just finding
someone that just worked and knowing
that that was probably going to be you
know my like quote forever
um and then I also have like which I
found out later going through this um
this journey I went to therapy
um this past year and realizing that I
have issues with my
my father so my biological father was in
and out of my life and then this past
like five years my stepfather kind of
abandoned me in certain ways so
realizing now when I look back at the
feelings that I had when I was going
into senior year I think it was I was
scared of commitment I think I'm I was
used to
having guys leave me and and or maybe I
just I don't have a permanent like male
figure in my life so looking back I
think that's what what kind of triggered
me to
um
kind of get scared with the relationship
with Edward and I so I ended up breaking
up with him
um which was really hard and looking
back on it he did not take it very well
he was very in love with me and I I was
of course in love with him but I think I
was just scared and then of course your
senior in high school and you have all
these outside influences I'm seeing my
friends dating and and you know
hooking up with guys or having attention
from guys and I didn't have that I just
went straight in from to have a
boyfriend and and
um just the fear of whoa this is really
serious so
that was really hard and that was
um looking back on it I probably wasn't
as nice to him as I should have been
um my thought was I couldn't be friends
with him
and not be with him and I think he
wanted some sort of relationship so I
was kind of I was really mean I would
say
um just because I was very firm that I
didn't really it was not easy for me to
do so that was a good like year of us
just kind of fighting back and forth
because he just wanted to have a
relationship with me and he cared for me
and I was just kind of stirring like we
can't have a relationship it was too
hard obviously I was going to get sucked
into
being with him again and that's not what
I wanted I just wanted to have a little
bit of of freedom and and experience
things
um so this was I it's hard to it's so
long ago but I remember he was a he was
going to at that time he had just
transferred to Marquette University in
Wisconsin I was working full-time
I graduated high school and I remember
at one point he called me out of the
blue and he was saying you know
I just I can't believe you know you
don't talk to me and I said what do you
mean I talked to you here and there and
he's like you have no idea what's going
on in my life he's like you don't know
what I'm studying you don't know
anything about me and he's like I'm just
kind of furious with you and it makes me
not want to ever talk to you again he
was really upset and I'd never seen him
like so upset
um
and so that kind of happened and we were
kind of figuring that out and um just
perfect timing uh a couple days later he
called me and he was like you know I
just I know we're fighting we're trying
to figure this out but I just wanted to
let you know that I'm probably going to
be coming home
and I said well why and he said
um I went to I would had I had the flu
um so I went to the school nurse
um while I was there I decided to have
my stomach checked because I had been
having stomach pain and he told me that
the nurse kind of felt um a lump a bump
of some sort and she was very concerned
about it and she advised that he go home
immediately and check with his doctor
and she and he told me he's like that's
not a good sign it could be cancer so he
came home and I want to say within that
week it's hard it's hard to it so long
ago it's hard to figure out timing but I
felt like it within that week he was
home and he was at the doctor he went to
UCLA and then he was immediately rushed
in for surgery because they couldn't
figure out if it was cancer or not so I
immediately just dropped what I was
doing I went to the hospital while he
was in surgery and I was really close
with his family at the time even when we
weren't together
we had that relationship where I would
still go over and see him and his
sisters his brother and his vice versa
so I had a very good relationship with
his family so I get there and um I was
trying to be strong and and not you know
I'm obviously nervous but I'm trying to
stay strong and not cause a scene for
his family who we were in the waiting
room they were fine they were they
weren't they they weren't crying or
anything they were kind of you know
keeping it together they're very
composed and um
yeah we're just waiting and I just
remember at one point his dad starts
crying and I just kind of lost it
because
seeing him cry and like them and not
distress are very happy people very very
positive
um
and that's when I kind of knew too I was
like okay this can't be good because if
they're crying and they're worried then
you know
scary so he got out of surgery and his
parents went in first I think they could
only do two at a time so his parents go
in
visit with him then I think his sisters
went and then I was going to go with his
brother who was probably like maybe
very young like under seven at the time
and I remember walking in and I remember
seeing I mean I don't I've never had
family members that have been sick I've
never had any sort of serious deaths in
the family so seeing him I walk in and
he's just got he's just like covered in
medical everything wires just tubes
packed like there's just he's just like
it just looked like a hospital it was
just like swallowing him whole and I
remember just being so overwhelmed that
he could barely talk and
I don't know what it was I was just like
okay I was in there for like four
minutes and I walked right out and um
his dad asked me he's like you didn't
want to stay and I literally couldn't
even I couldn't even talk like it was
the most overwhelming thing to see
someone you love
looking like that and so
um
yeah that was a hard day and I remember
him texting me like you know why'd you
leave so early and I was like you have
no idea what you look like like it was
just to this day like it's still like
like it's it's tough to even like
picture but um that was like the start
of a very long year
um he ended up coming staying home
obviously he had a very invasive surgery
he hadn't ended up having almost like a
a football-sized tumor on his kidney he
had his kidney removed and it was a long
recovery just the surgery alone and then
he ended up doing uh chemo I think he
did
he was at UCLA Santa Monica and he did
uh like every two or three weeks he did
like a round of two days worth of chemo
and then he would wait two three weeks
and he would do like a week-long of
chemo so he was always in and out of the
hospital I ended up
just
um
I was and I was working full time at the
time but what I would do is if I had
work or if I was getting off of work I
would go down there and I would hang out
with him or if I had work the next day I
would go down there spend the night and
leave to work and I live in Ventura
County so that drive was super long but
you know
I think that showed the love that I had
for him because that was nothing like I
would do that I had no problem I never
never complained I never thought of it
as like a a task I just wanted to be
there for him and I wanted to be
involved and know what was going on
um
so that was hard he started to lose his
hair
um so you could start to see he started
getting skinny he was having all these
these health issues obviously that went
along with chemo but
um I remember too he would always say
like so I should back up so we were not
together it was just me being there for
him but obviously like I had mentioned
we had no issues so just
us being together and just that love
rekindling I guess or just me being
there we just ended up getting back
together of course because
it's just that we were just I was drawn
to him he was drawn to me it just it is
what it was what it was and that so we
ended up getting back together we were
official boyfriend and girlfriend
um and I remember he told me one day he
was like I you know we would tell each
other we love you and I'd be like you
know I would I still thought he was so
handsome and he would joke he's like I
look like Voldemort because he had no
hair or anything and I just specifically
remember like I don't remember him
looking different
yes he did have you really looked at him
yeah he had no hair he looked different
but to me it was like the boy that I
loved the guy that I loved from high
school
and again I just think that showed like
the love that I had for him because he
didn't look he just looked like him you
know he looked like the guy that I loved
um and ironically that whole year that
he was in the hospital was probably one
of my favorite moments or times with him
because there would be like he would
stay at a week a week at a time and
it was just it was just time that we had
together like we would listen to music
and he would he would show me different
things and we would our thing was movies
like our whole relationship was always
movies we loved to go to movies uh we
love to see movies we were just very
into that so we'd watch movies all the
time
um they had like he was in the Pediatric
even though he was he was like 19 at the
time it was a pediatric floor so they
had Guitar Hero and I would always
always be like can you please like Mario
can we please get play Guitar Hero and
he never went to play but he would just
I loved it so that was like a funny
thing and the nurses would always be
like you're playing again like it was
just I just cherished that time because
it was time that we had together and and
even though he was going through
something so serious it was just such a
positive thing for us to just be
together and and just have those moments
you know and
um even though we were in a hospital it
was like we forgot that he was sick for
a little bit that's just how I felt like
it was just us being kids again having
fun
um so it was about a year of him um
doing that he finally got the green
light the cancer was gone
such a blessing it was a great time he
was done with chemo
um and he was having PL he made plans to
go back to school and this is where
again my commitment issues come in
um I for some reason decided we're not
doing long distance it's not a good idea
when you go back to school we're just
gonna cut it off we're gonna be friends
um I don't know why I mean I do know why
but I also I I don't know what part of
me didn't think like maybe we could just
try this out but he was very he's very
much I was very much
a very strong-willed independent
outspoken person and he is very just
reserved very good with the flow very
easy so I think he didn't even fight it
he just kind of let me
make a call I guess they're just okay
and I remember he left and as soon as he
left like that week I was like I made
the wrong decision I made the wrong
decision
um I was like no I I can't do this
so I called him expecting him to be like
okay yeah but I got a big reality check
he was like you know what Melissa you
can't you can't call the shots like that
like you can't just say we're not going
to be together and then change your mind
and expect that to you know
go back to that like this and so that
was really hard and I'm not used to
being told no especially by him
um he's very much like whatever I want
he's very he was very kind very uh sweet
in that way so that began a very long
year of
um us fighting
um also because I mean I think I had to
I it was very and this is one of my
regrets too because I was very selfish
in that way
um a part of me felt like I gave up a
lot to be there for him that whole year
I was there for him and I would do it
over again but I felt like once he went
back it's almost like he forgot about me
which in the end I know that's not his
intention and that wasn't the case but I
was being selfish at the time I'm young
um
and in reality I had to think about the
fact that he had he didn't know if he
was going to even live and he went from
beating cancer and I think two weeks
later he was back in in Wisconsin
just like like he went from zero to a
hundred you know going back to school he
was on the rugby team he was the captain
of the rugby team he was working
full-time he did an internship so
um he didn't really have a lot of time
to give to me and I was used to that and
um so that caused a lot of problems
with with us a lot of a lot of issues
um I even but even then even with those
like we still had a pretty good
relationship overall like I even visited
him one time and we had the best week
like he showed me around I met all of
his friends
um
um I still stay close to this family and
um
um yeah so that was that and then he
came home I'm trying to think I think he
graduated or no he didn't graduate he
was he was there for about a year maybe
two years and then I was working
full-time I was going to school at that
time and um again so probably the second
worst thing could ever happen he gave me
a call one day and he said
um you know I went to my routine
doctor's appointment and uh there's
something that they see inside me and
it's not looking good
and
I don't
that was obvious like I don't even have
words I don't know I don't remember
taking it as bad as the first time but
also I remember thinking in the back of
my head and I never I've never said this
to anyone but I just remember being like
no one no one survives this twice you
know rarely do I know anyone that
survived cancer twice especially being
the kind of cancer he had in his age
um that was honestly the first thing I
thought of but of course I'm gonna be
there for him so he came home same thing
um I was there for him and we we did
doctor's appointments together and I was
there for every surgery he had a port
put in he had
um different kinds of surgeries and then
same thing like we just again there is
no issues between us so we just ended up
getting back together
um and again like
I think that's important part of this
story is like through the the bad
there's so much good like
again we created so many fun memories
together like what that time the second
time he had cancer
um he was a huge Dodger fan he'd always
he'd always been and we had so much time
I think between my schedule and him not
working and so we just went to Dodger
games like we I can't tell you how many
Dodger games we went to that was just
like our thing we always went um he had
friends that came in from Wisconsin we
took them there
um that was just I just I just remember
doing that and um he had different kinds
of chemo treatments and he had radiation
so I would go with him to that
um we still had time to do such so many
things
um and then I remember it was about a
year and a half again and again this is
where my patterns come in I noticed like
after a year year and a half right
before two years is when I started to
feel those like
commitment issues come on and I remember
we were fighting so much and I don't
even remember what we were fighting over
honestly I I really don't but we were
fighting over stupid things and I just
remember thinking you know
he's going through all this the last
thing I want is to bring our stupid
issues onto his plate when he has bigger
things to deal with
um at that point it was like a year year
and a half like I said and the cancer
wasn't getting much better
it was kind of stagnant he also wasn't
receiving medical treatment from UCLA he
was not Kaiser and the doctor he had was
not very informed on that kind of cancer
which was scary and he was undergoing
like certain treatments that weren't
approved yet like those like trials I
guess you could say so it was just a
very stressful part of his life and mine
too just dealing with a lot at the time
I was probably like 22-23
and so I made we made the decision to
you know let's just be friends because
he it was starting to be like a
resentment thing like I would do little
things and he would resent me for and
then we would bring up those issues it
was just things that didn't need to be
dealt with at that time
um and I remember I we broke up like I
think it was it was Fourth of July and
that day we broke up that day and then
that night we still hung out with each
other so it's just that just is a little
glimpse of just how we were even though
we weren't
and the best place to be together like I
it was always him and I together
um and so we still maintained a
relationship I remember like a couple
months later his his parent Grandparents
were having an anniversary party in
Maryland I went with his whole family
um they still treated me like family
like his his family still still loved me
just the same
um like I had him over for dinner a lot
like it was just still a great
relationship
um and I remember there was one time
um we were going to the movies we were
coming back from the movies and I can
still picture like exactly where we were
on the freeway like where we were and I
remember him saying uh you know Melissa
like I don't know if you and I will end
up together but he said I know you were
meant for me and he said it's so matter
of factly he was like I don't know if
we'll ever be together but I know you
were meant for me I know I was meant for
you and we are meant to be together and
um to this day I wish I had said I just
remember being quiet but saying I agreed
but I wish now where I'm at now I wish I
had I wish I'd told them more I wish I
had gone deeper but I I'll never forget
that moment in the car
um
and so fast forward
um
we were still friends kind of doing our
own thing and I've always struggled with
like I said commitment issues but I
think I'm on top of that
um I've never known anything without him
in my life and I'm getting older at this
point I'm like 23 24 and I feel that
he's the one for me but also you know
you go in this this phase of doubt you
know and you're you're seeing outside
influences like I'm seeing my friends
date I'm seeing my you know my my peers
you know getting married dating
different people loving different people
and I've only loved one person in my
life and so I've always struggled with
moving on
um and dating other people because Edwin
was in my life
um partly too because no one's ever made
me feel the way that he's made me feel
no one's ever stood up to his level
um and I knew that if I was going to
move on if I was going to have someone
else to call my boyfriend like it that
was a big step to
to move on and have someone else so I I
just that wasn't something that I was
willing to do for just anybody and same
with him he never when we weren't
together he never I mean he kind of
dated a couple people but it wasn't
really serious
um so I feel like he felt the same way
and same thing if he was gonna actually
call someone else's girlfriend like it
was going to be a big deal and so
um this was fast forward I want to say
like 2019 it was around like September
we had hung out and I remember we went
to a movie Just Friends and he had a
sweatshirt on and I noticed that he had
it looked like
like a little like a little pillowcase
almost and I was like what is that he's
like oh I have like a
um I forget what it's called like he had
like some swelling on his intestines and
I was like well you're gonna get that
checked out and he said well the doctor
is not really too concerned about it so
he doesn't think that it needs to be
taken out or removed
um
he's like it's a little enlarged but
that's it and so I remember I just
remember that and and we we went and saw
the movie everything was fine
and then after that we were kind of
arguing back and forth because I would
always say that you know I was always
putting in this effort but I felt like
he wasn't getting it back and again I
think that was selfishness on my part
because I have to think about what he's
going through and you know all that's on
his plate but again that was just my
mindset at the time and so we were kind
of bickering back and forth and at that
point I was like you know what I don't
know anything other than him being in my
life I said you know
he's not making this effort I'm at this
point where I don't I maybe I should try
to date other people maybe I should try
to not have him be so a part of my life
so that I can see if you know
if maybe if if we are meant to be
together you know that's my mindset and
um again I I always felt too guilty for
a so part of me felt guilty because he
was sick and I was always worried that
if I had kind of straight away a little
too much and something happened then I
would feel really remorse I would feel
guilty because
I you know I I wasn't closer I didn't
know like I always wanted to be close
enough where I knew updates I knew it
was what was going on with him but I
said you know what and I had a lot of
talks with my family my mom my best
friends like you know I like should I
kind of separate us a little bit and at
the time I thought it was a good idea
because again that's I met him when I
was 15 and at this time I'm like 24 you
know that's I know nothing but him I we
were so intertwined maybe this was a
good idea
and so it was about like a month or two
him and I just hadn't really talked and
I was kind of upset because he hadn't he
hadn't reached out to me hadn't made an
effort
um so I remember it was like October I
was at my little brother's like
Championship football game and his
sister and I have a good relationship
and um
I was at the game and his sister called
me and I didn't answer because it was
loud and I texted her I said hey what's
up and she just said call me when you
can and I remember I just knew I was
like that is not that nothing that's not
good I didn't know what that call was
going to be but I knew that it wasn't
anything good so I remember going
underneath the bleachers and I remember
his sister telling me
um you know the cancer has gotten bad
and
there's nothing that doctors can do
anymore
um so they sent him home and they just
said that he doesn't they don't know how
much longer he has
um and I I was just I like was in shock
like and you know of course like I feel
guilt automatically for not knowing this
um I just talked to him like a month or
two before you know so for it to get
that bad I was just in shock and so
I had a conversation with her had all
the questions and um went back up with
my with my family and I remember looking
at my mom and she's like is everything
okay and I just looked at her and I just
shook my head and I had to I didn't want
to talk about it but I remember
um
that was just the longest game ever I
would I mean it was just like it's like
it was so loud but I feel like
everything was so quiet and it's like I
could not focus that's all I was
thinking about and it's like our whole
relationship everything had just flashed
before me that's all I was thinking
about
um and at the time I had just moved to
North Hollywood I literally had been
living there for like two weeks I had
gotten my own apartment it was my first
time without living with my parents I
was living close to work and I remember
my grandma dropped me off and I just
cried myself to sleep that night and um
I ended up texting him and again like
now that I think back I wish I would
have just called him
um but I just couldn't I don't think I
one I didn't want to alarm him
and I didn't want to alarm him with my
feelings
um but I also just couldn't I don't
think I could talk to him so I texted
him and I was asking him everything was
okay and he was just kind of informing
me what was going on and I said well do
you want to come over and get out of the
house for a little bit and he's like
well I can't really because I have some
medicines I have to take some bandages
and I was like you can bring those with
you you know and he was like well we'll
see and I said well I'm working tomorrow
tomorrow was Sunday the next day was
Sunday and I work only Thursday through
Sunday so I said after work I'll come by
can I come see you and he said yes of
course
and I remember waking up the next day
like my eyes were like like
twice the size that they were I was just
I had a rash everywhere I I had to go to
work and pretend like nothing was wrong
and so I go to see him and um
uh like he just 100 downplayed the
severity of his condition like he made
it seem like oh like I have some
bandages it's not he could barely get up
he looked like a skeleton I mean like
his hair was receding
um you could see like his bones on his
whole face like his collarbone and he
looked like he had like a huge like
queen size pillow on his stomach which
later was the intestines he basically
had like an open wound because his skin
was stretched so much from the
um
the wound in his intestines that it was
just bulging and it was growing and it
was getting it was it was I it was a
hernia it was something like that and I
just remember like it's almost like it
like hit you like my throat started to
burn
like it was overwhelming I was not
expecting to see him like that
um and I had to just kind of play it
cool
and just kind of like like suck it up
and so I was talking to him for a little
bit and I was like oh why don't we get
us lunch you know and he was like I'll
go with you and he couldn't even get out
of bed like that was when I knew I was
like holy [ __ ] this is real
um so I said you know what I'll get
lunch
um I went out to my car and I like cried
so hard like it was almost like holding
that in it was it was overwhelming and
to this day like I have one picture that
his dad took of us while we were there
and I look at it and it's like it wasn't
the same Edward that I knew
um
so
um that was hard but I mean again like I
was gonna be there for him no matter
what
um and so I ended up going so I had I
ended up staying I went over every day
that I could and it's funny because I
knew how important I was to him and I
knew our relationship but I was still so
subtle I was like well if you don't want
me to come over like I was very shy and
asking to see him when all I wanted to
do was be with him until he woke up till
he went to bed like I would have spent
the night there all four days but I just
felt like I was overbearing which again
another regret of mine I wish I had
taken every day that I could up with him
um but I ended up you know he was like
yeah you can come over and we would
watch all these movies and
um I remember there was one time I went
over there and
um
I
we were watching a movie and he had
fallen asleep and I had I was holding
his hand and I I didn't want to ever
express how
scared I was to lose him I didn't
Express anything that I wanted to I just
wanted to keep it kind of casual and
just a beat for him because he was in a
hospital bed in his room we had there
was a priest that came and was talking
to him about how he wanted to be buried
like it was very very serious so I
didn't want to add to that you know but
um we were watching a movie and he had
fallen asleep and I grabbed his hand I
just remember like holding his hand and
like smelling it and just like was
sobbing sobbing um just knowing that I
wouldn't get that I didn't know how much
longer and
um
just it was just sad you know um I can't
really explain it but
um
so I did that for about two or three
weeks I can't really remember
um it was all of like it was right after
November so
um it was December his birthday was
November 21st
um and it was December 21st
um
December 21st he was
um
he was at home and it was I was my
Sunday I believe it was like my last day
at work and then I was gonna go see him
that night and I remember my
grandparents actually came by and they
um came by my work and gave him gave me
a Christmas card for him
um like they do every year
um and I remember that day I had texted
him and I said
um you know my grandparents gave you a
card I want to bring it by
and he hadn't gotten back to me and I
thought it was just because
um I thought it was just because he was
um thank you sorry
um I thought it was just because you
know he was sleeping and and that night
we were doing like a gift exchange at
work and um
um his sister called me and I remember
going outside and she just said she said
he's gone
um
again like how do you process that you
know I remember I was crying and I just
couldn't I just I couldn't believe it
and I I realized that that text message
he hadn't gotten it he had already
passed
um and so I I cried my my co-workers
were super supportive they came out and
they you know they got me an Uber
to go home and end up calling my mom and
I told her I was like mommy's gone
and she starts falling because she loved
him like she would always say like I
don't want you to get married but then I
was like then she'd be like but you can
marry Edwin like she was always like if
you guys got married now it'd be perfect
I'd be fine you know
um and so I remember getting an Uber I
remember going over there and
um I don't I don't know what had
happened but I think in the midst of me
getting my stuff and panicking and
calling somehow his messages from him
and I his text messages were erased and
that was like super hard
um
I had in the 10 years that we'd been
together I had never deleted any of our
text messages ever ever I'd always had
them and so I was like super crushed
because
um we had had some talks like since he
found out that he wasn't going to be
living much longer some sweet things
that he said to me
um
so um I was really upset that those were
gone
um I ended up going
um to his house and everyone was there
everyone was there and I remember just
seeing
um he was in there in in the room
um and I will say like I'm pretty strong
for the most part so seeing him there
um ironically was not super hard because
I know that wasn't him it was just his
body but it really set in
um his parents were pretty
um
positive they weren't really crying
um everyone was kind of was settled
because they had been there for a while
and so I was kind of like keeping it
together
um
and I stayed there for like five hours
five six I can't even remember I was
like I'm not leaving until they kicked
me out here I didn't want to I didn't
want to leave
um I stayed there until the mortuary
came and picked him up and that was
really hard they let me go in there and
say goodbye to him
um which was also really hard because I
mean it's just I mean not having that
physical form of someone will always be
hard and so knowing that that was the
last time I could feel him and touch him
and
um
that was hard but um they took him away
and um my mom picked me up and um
I'm very independent I'm very strong I'm
very um I'm very I'm very strong person
but I remember I was like Mom I need you
to sleep with me like I just I couldn't
even I couldn't I didn't have I slept at
my mom's house I I needed her I needed
someone and I remember the first three
days were I I never ever wish that upon
anyone I always explain that grief is
so much worse pain than any physical
pain that you'll ever feel I can't
explain it but it's like something that
you can't take away and nothing makes it
feel better it's just in the deepest
part of you and those first three days I
truly didn't know how I was going going
to
continue on with life I didn't I
remember I was staying in my sister's
room at the time and I remember just
calling my mom over and over just just
screaming crying
because it was just so painful and I
didn't even get out of bed I didn't eat
I remember throwing up a couple times
just from being so emotional
um
and um one thing that I think people
when you lose someone no one ever talks
about the guilt
um you think that you talk you think
about the good times and all this like I
didn't think about anything good with us
I only thought about
what I could have done different
um the month that I was mad at him could
have been a month that I was there for
him you know and that's why I explained
earlier about how you know I decided to
take a break and separate
um I still feel extreme guilt over that
because of course the time that I decide
to do that is the time that you know
probably would have meant the world to
him and me to be there
um I also remember just all those times
as a kid just taking him for granted and
just being selfish and you know
everyone's really sweet to me and and
says you know oh Melissa like you
weren't selfish you were you didn't know
this that you know whatever they say to
make me feel better but
um in in this time that I've taken after
he's passed I realized that I was
selfish in a lot of ways and I didn't
like the person that I was
um
but it's hard when you can't say sorry
for those things like I can't I couldn't
tell him I was sorry I couldn't tell him
that you know I wish I had done better I
wish I'd been better for him um which is
the hardest part
um and so for the Latin in the next
three days like I was just a mess and um
I had some old old text messages backed
up on my computer and I remember I I
spent days just looking at those I would
take 30 minutes and I would look at them
and I didn't want to
look at them all at once because I
didn't want them to be over like it was
like that that time that I had that he
was still there and so for the next
couple days I was just like looking at
those
um text messages and at the end it was
text messages where we were fighting
where he was saying he wanted to be with
me and I was saying no and I obviously
wasn't the nicest so that triggered a
lot more guilt because that was the last
piece of like our conversations that I
had of him because I didn't have those
other text messages and so I was really
in a bad place I was really I was really
bad I I didn't get out of bed and um I
remember my mom telling me she's like
Melissa I I am really worried for you
um she's like I think you need to see
someone and I said fine whatever so um I
went and saw a therapist
um which was helpful
um I actually got to see my mom too my
mom's not much of a
um she doesn't Voice a lot of her
um
feelings
um but she cried and she said she was
scared she'd never seen me like this
and she was scared for my well-being
um
and I remember telling the therapist too
I said like I I never wanted to kill
myself I've never felt suicidal but I
just remembered telling her that if a
car hit me I would be fine I would I
would be fine going now
um I think part of that was also knowing
that I would be able to see Edwin in
heaven
that was like my process but also too
it's just I truly did not know how I was
ever going to feel happy again like I I
did not think that that was a
possibility
um even like songs like I would listen
to songs and like I couldn't there was
only three songs that I could listen to
everything it just like it was too happy
it was too like I couldn't I couldn't do
anything
um and so that was scary too knowing
that you know that was that was my
mindset
um but I ended up going um I ended up
going to therapy sticking to it I would
go once a week
um
and we would just kind of try to deal
with the guilt that I had with Edwin
um
I'm trying to think I don't
it was just it was a really it was a
hard hard time for sure like me trying
to and and not only that but knowing
that nothing could help me feel better
you know like he's he's gone he's gone
and and there's nothing that could bring
him back that I can't I just wanted like
one more time to talk to him you know
um but it was really nice I mean
um
when I I posted on Instagram you know
that he had passed and I got so many so
many sweet sweet messages from people
um people that didn't really know us
that well but like
were like he was such a regret like I
knew I always knew you guys to love each
other this not so it kind of made me
that part made me feel better because I
felt like I was this horrible person and
like I kind of doubted the relationship
that we had like and it was really nice
to see people from the outside see how
much
love that we had for each other
um and so and I remember like his
funeral came and a lot of my friends and
family came and were super supportive
um
that part I I like I don't even remember
that part like I just remember that part
being like a blur to
um I wasn't really
I wasn't really sad at that point it was
more like when I was on my own like when
I was in front of people it was fine I
was really strong
but then I would go home and I would
just I mean everything and everything
reminded me of him you know everything
um and over the over this next couple of
years of me trying to get better and
trying to deal with the grief that I had
I didn't realize like how much he was
like my other like my other half and how
much I depended on him like looking back
I remember one time my dog was attacked
and passed away and my mom was in a
panic and I remember the first call I
made was him
um
like any time I wanted to do something
fun like I've always wanted to go to
Alcatraz and so he was the one that went
with me like we just we were so
intertwined and like anytime I had
issues with my mom or family life
anything like he was always the first
one that I went to and so
um realizing that I didn't have him
anymore was really hard really hard
because I at that point my parents were
having issues they were they were in the
process of getting divorced and um I was
having issues with my stepdad and my
biological dad was no longer there he
was trying to get back in the picture
and so I it was a time where I also
really needed him and that hurt a lot
knowing that I didn't have that person
anymore
um
and it's still it still hurts like I I
tell everyone like I feel I've never
felt more lonely
in these past couple years than I ever
have
um because it's just use that person
like you said in that one time in the
car he was he was he was that person for
me
um
and it's a lot to deal with especially
at my age I mean I don't
I mean his family and so many other
people have dealt with so much worse
than me you know I'm but like I don't
know anyone that's lost a loved one
being their first boyfriend at the age
of 25 you know like that's I don't know
it's hard it's hard to deal with but um
um I went to therapy and I was I was
dealing with a lot of other things that
I didn't realize were
also made me the way that I am so and I
was dealing with guilt with Edwin but I
was also taking care of myself in
another in other ways
um and you know what I'm the type of
person where I don't like to sit in my
sorrows I don't like to be in a negative
space so I said you know what if I'm
gonna be happy if I'm going to continue
on and I'm going to keep being positive
and continue out my life I need to do
something different
um and at the same time I was talking to
his sister and his two sisters
um they're one one's a year younger than
me and one is like two or three years
younger than me and um
I would go over there sometimes and we
would just talk about him and we would
cry together and I would explain like
you know
we would talk about a lot of things and
his sister was honestly
the most
helpful in the sense of me trying to get
back on track with my life because she
was just saying you know
a lot of people would say why him why
him why did he die
and she said I'll never forget this she
said of course it was him she's like if
it were me if it were you the impact
wouldn't be as great
um because it was him you know there
were so many people that went to his
funeral and there were so many people
that um were impacted by him
um that of course it was him and I I
would always say like you know I just I
really like I want to see him like I
want to go to heaven I want to see him
and she's like but it's not our time
Melissa she would say he did what he
needed to do
um
to go and that's another that's a whole
other level of spirituality and
religious
um conversations but I mean she kind of
painted that picture that like he did
everything that he needed to do here
um and she had conversations with him
where she said that he was he was okay
like he was in that space where he was
ready to go not ready to go but he was
okay with going
um
and I remember he she said she had a
conversation with him and he said you
know make sure everyone's okay I'm gonna
be okay and I remember being the the
just I was I'm so um I'm so like tough
skinned sometimes and I was like I never
said I was gonna be okay I never said
that I was gonna be fine without him you
told him that not me
um but I've had many conversations with
her that I knew that
I needed to do something different I
needed to get my life on track so I had
been
um working since high school as uh to do
hair and makeup I built a really big um
name for myself I guess with hair and
makeup I'd done so many things I was
working very hard to move um in the
direction to do hair and makeup and I
just thought I was like you know what I
need to do something more fulfilling
like I need to do I feel I felt so much
guilt and so much so just such like a
shitty person for what I had done with
him and the regrets that I had with him
that I I knew that I could never change
that nor could I ever tell him
what I was going to tell him
um I could not
have a talk with him so in my mind I
needed to do something to bring out more
good like you know what I mean like if
if I can't change this I'm gonna try to
be the best person I can be moving
forward to kind of cancel out and to
kind of um you know
make up for this time and so I said you
know what the easiest way I can change
that is my job right like
um
I was like you know hair makeup I've
been doing it for so long it wasn't
really a challenge anymore it wasn't
really
um as fulfilling as it once was and so I
was like well what can I do that like
has purpose and so at the time I was
like you know I could be a nurse because
all the nurses that helped him
throughout his journey were amazing and
I was like you know I'd have to go
through nursing school to do that so I'm
like I'm definitely not doing that and
then I thought okay well I can't do the
military that's not you know and these
are all like big you know jobs that are
like very fulfilling you know the cheesy
like you know like helping others and
then I landed on being a police officer
and that like I thought about it in
immediate I was like no because I'm very
girly I am very I've never been athletic
um
and so I thought about that and I was
like wait a minute like could I do that
and the idea of of working towards
something and doing something that was
so out of my comfort zone is something
that I do and so I spent about a good
like two months thinking about if this
was the right decision for me
um and I said you know what I I love
this I love that it's it's this that job
forces you to be a good person like it
challenges you to be the best person you
could be and there's a lot of negative
things in law enforcement there's a lot
of things that can
taint the way that you think there's it
can be a mentally draining job but it
does if you do it right it it forces you
to be the best that you can be and to
help others and to just put yourself on
the back burner and at the time
that's all I was wanting I was wanting
to just put a put my selfishness aside
all the selfishness that I've had for
the past years
um
and and just do good for other people
um and so I decided to do that and after
a year and a half I did I ended up
getting into an agency and I got into
the police academy and I graduated and
I'm now a police officer I've been up
not that long but I've been a police
officer for
um almost a year now and um it's the
best best thing that could have ever
happened to me and I just it makes me
happy because Edwin had everything to do
with it he had like everything to do
with this Choice
um and I think about it every day
um when I'm at work and I think about
how like
as much as I would love him here like he
didn't he didn't go in vain like he he
I'm a totally different person how I was
when I met him to now and um
I know that God had had that in my plan
in my life
um
and it's just it just feels good too I
mean I feel like I you know knowing that
I was going to do this interview I was
trying to think back at how I felt
um the guilt that I felt and I honestly
couldn't remember exactly what I felt
and I that kind of showed me that I had
grown so much and that this job and and
this journey has helped me
um now I can think of just the good
memories that I have with him and I can
think of
um you know I always say that yes I lost
him but I am so thankful to be able to
have experienced love like true love
like movie love unconditional love
because not everyone thinks that not
everyone
gets that in their life and I would take
10 of those years rather than none you
know
um and I think about him in in so many
different ways I mean I always say too
him he's like elevator music to me or
like when you go into a store
you don't really realize that there's
music playing but if the music shuts off
you're like wait a minute there was that
there's no music like I think of him in
that way like he's not even like a real
thought
it's in the back of my mind but he's
always there like I'll be thinking
talking to someone and he's always in
the back of my mind always
um and even like so
something that's really special to me is
at work we have to wear obviously a
watch
um when I went for our first Christmas
together back when we were 15 16 I
bought him this G-Shock watch it was his
first G-Shock watch everyone was wearing
them
um I bought him one for Christmas
um and then when he passed away I asked
his sister if I could have it so that's
actually the watch that I wear to work
every day
um which is really special because it's
the one that I got him and it just makes
me think of him and it just reminds me
of of you know how much he's helped me
and how much I'm just super thankful for
the good and the bad memories and
um
just everything that I went through with
him I mean I don't know it's hard to
wrap up like all that and
and and just conclude it but um
yeah so I've and I still deal with it to
this day like
there's times where I'm super happy and
um I'm okay and and I think about like
dating again and there's times where I'm
just like I I don't know how I I go back
to that spot where it's like how can I
how could I ever move on from loving him
and I think about like I still have so
many years before I see him again
um
but I mean I just try to take it day by
day and it's helpful that um I have a
lot of family and friends that still
talk to me about him and
um just the other day my best friend she
she was she told me that she was in her
room with her boyfriend and she was
listening to Pandora or whatever and a
Kid Cudi song came on and she said she
went and her boyfriend was like what and
she's like nothing nothing and he's like
no what's going on and she's like it
just reminds me of Edwin and and her
boyfriend who's never met Edwin
was like tell me more about him
and the fact that my best friend still
thinks about him and the fact that you
know other people that never knew him
want to know about him
um just it makes me happy you know what
I mean and um I'm still super close to
this family and that makes me super
happy like they his dad still says like
my other daughter
um I remember
um
always saying I wanted to go to El
Salvador I always wanted to go I've
never been able to go and
um I told his mom I said next time you
go I want to go with you and this was
when he was still alive we'd always said
that and um I had always been more
comfortable with his family than my own
family weirdly
um so last year she was going and um
she said she's like We're going to El
Salvador do you want to go and I said
absolutely and so we went and we were on
the trip and I remember his mom was um
his mom said she's she said she's like
we we went he always we always told him
that we would go and um she said she
wished he was obviously here with us but
um that we still get to do things like
this is really great
um
um so that I mean that was just all
forever cherished that and the fact that
we can still I can still be close with
his family
is very special to me
um
and it's still it's weird because it you
it's it's nice being with this family
and it feels it feels like him when I S
when I'm with them
I feel him and in good ways and in bad
ways like um there's like when we were
in El Salvador I remember there's one
part of the trip where he his dad was
dancing with
um his aunt so brother and sister and
we're outside and like everyone's around
and they're dancing and his dad is such
a silly guy and his dad his dad was like
dancing all funny and it's just crazy I
remember thinking like oh my God Edwin
would love to see this right now Edwin
would be laughing and I tried to hold
back tears
um
so there's moments like that that I get
all the time like it's just out of
nowhere like these little like it's like
being shot like shot with like a BB gun
or something it's like just an instant
sting I don't know how to explain it um
and even then like I'll make an effort
to go to his house all the time and um I
don't think anything of it and then I
pull up and um
when I pull up it's just like that same
feeling of just like oh like it's just
memories of you know when I used to pull
up there as a kid and and just knowing
that I'm gonna see his picture and um
just so many memories in there so it's
still hard and um his family says that
about me too like I I didn't think that
it would affect them but they said his
sister said you know I knew you were
coming over one day and um I was driving
home to come meet you and I just started
crying
um because you still remind us of my
brother and all those times and um so I
mean that's something I mean it's a good
and bad thing because I mean that means
that you know that's how special he was
and I mean I'm thankful for that because
that means that he I worry my biggest
worry was
um not forgetting him but having those
memories be more faint and faint when
someone initially dies like you just I
you feel everything all these memories
come back to you like everything and I
was worried that as time goes on you
know I'm I'm almost gonna be 30 now
and what happened when I was in my teens
and my 20s this feels like so long ago I
never want to forget that but um so
that's like one of my biggest fears is
you know whatever happens in my life if
I get married again if I don't or you
know if I get old like I just never want
to forget all those times
um
so that's why this is I mean I feel like
this is really special to be able to to
do this interview and and to get this on
film
um in this time in my life and I feel
like I'm actually in a good place where
I still deal with the grief and the
guilt and missing him but I'm in a good
place and it's just a new me and um I
say it all the time like I wouldn't be
the new me and I feel so good about me
and who I am and how much growing I've
done and I know that it wouldn't be
without him and his impact and
even when he was gone so
um I still have some grind to do but I
just um I'm just yeah I I love him and I
can't wait till I can see him again but
until then like he's always here and
he's always making an impact on me and
he's always he's always there and um
making me a better person so yeah
your story of course beautiful story